foreign
Jason what was uh just your viewpoint on
that final play and the uh the swing of
emotions you guys had in that you know
final three seconds there
[Music]
oh my God
that was incredible
um
man
uh we drew up a play
they kind of took the way that you know
you know I was trying to get the ball
Jimmy and Spruce jumped out to me smart
came in and shot it and we just crashed
the glass
and everything was like a blur after
that
uh you know D white tipped it in
but you know that felt like the longest
10 seconds ever waiting for
confirmation if you made it or not uh
I'm still like in disbelief that
was crazy
um
but you know I'm glad we got another
chance another opportunity
you know it's far from over
still uphill battle but I
feel good to give yourself another
chance another opportunity